starring to be talking about gas gateway
it's my name is Jim Chris I work at
anaconda I've been here for about five
years now started when yours continuum
quick show of hands how many of you have
heard of desk before Wow excellent how
many of you have used desk before okay
cool all right so for those of you that
don't know we'll start with a quick
overview and then we'll move on to what
we're talking about so desk is a
flexible parallel library you're a
flexible library for parallel computing
provides a familiar API for writing
scalable analytics using the PI data
ecosystem so we have desk array which
looks a lot like an empire dasa
different looks like pandas desk amount
looks a lot like scikit-learn these are
mostly drop-ins if you're used to using
one the other shouldn't usually work for
you with a little change to your code
it's designed to scale formula single
machine to a large distributed cluster
your same application code should be
able to run usually in multiple contexts
with only a couple changes to how you're
deploying it and a deeper level it looks
a little like this user write some code
this is just - two different which looks
like pandas read some CSV is to group by
whatever familiar-looking Python code
behind the scenes - generates a task
graph this is description of the
computation this is a set of tasks that
need to be done in some order and they
can usually be done in parallel and then
to ask schedules those tasks across a
cluster so here we have a scheduler and
a bunch of workers these tasks can be
distributed throughout that based on the
schedulers logic delving into that last
bit a little bit more this is what the
cluster looks like at a lower level we
have a scheduler the scheduler is in
charge of managing all of the things
that are going on at the time in the
cluster the scheduler says where tasks
should run it managers communication
with workers it finds dead workers and
rubens tasks and it also talks to a
client the client process here isn't on
the cluster that's what's living in your
script in your notebook whatever that's
on on the users end of things
the scheduler and the workers live
somewhere
else in customer one of the hardest
parts of distributing is how you
actually end up with one of these how do
you deploy your code how do you actually
interface with the backend so we have a
whole stack of things than have to go on
here so we have in dowsed something we
call a cluster manager this is an object
that exists in your Python code deploy
is a scheduler and many workers by
talking to a resource manager resource
manager is anything from crew nannies to
yarn to if you work in a place they
might have an HPC system you might be
familiar with slurring or PBS this is
the thing that actually gives you
resources this thing that gives you
memory and cores to run your processes
on figures out what notify cluster to
run things on and then that's all either
in the cloud or on a physical Hardware
but your local but it needs to be
running on a computer somewhere the
cloud is computers they just might not
be yours so we have a whole tier of
abstractions that we need to work with
here this talk is mostly going to be
focusing on this bit so cluster manager
is the thing we have in desk it's a
Python object it's a base class actually
that you can implement with many
different backends so desk provides ones
for kubernetes with the - kubernetes
project yarn with tasks yarn HPC job
queues - job queue we have a new issue
one for doing cloud native stuff sort of
deploy directly on ec2 standard
interface you create an object it's got
two methods scale you pass in a number
it scales it gives you that many workers
and adapt you can say I want to
adaptively scale between men and a max
and that will look at your workload and
it'll say if you could use more workers
we'll try to give them to you and if you
don't need as many workers so scale down
it helps you not use too many resources
anyway centered a dark-type interface
creative cluster it works example code
might look like this this might be a
script or part of your notebook you
import for a back-end here we're using
Basque yarn so from task your iron
import yarn cluster we create a cluster
object we ask for workers we're afraid
of cluster object we passing things that
might be specific to the backend so here
we're saying what Python
want to use we want to have two cores
per worker and eight gigs per worker
then you connect and you write your
application code your connections a
cluster everything else transparently
runs on that the only part that's
specific to the back-end in this case
yarn is this bit
everything else is generic it would work
with any other cluster manager as I said
before we have different ones so you
just swap out those lines for creating a
coop cluster instead or a PBS cluster so
that's the status quo that's how things
have been working in the past there's
some nice things about this
so deployment is part of users code
there's no need for extra steel ID tools
there's no spark submit for tasks you
create your cluster in your script you
run your code it shuts down when your
script ends I can work just from scripts
and work from notebooks can be part of a
larger application deployment as part of
code is got a lot of nice features for
it there's no need for extra
infrastructure all of these projects are
designed to work natively with the
backing resource manager so for example
desk yarn integrates really well with
the the hadoop yarn resource manager it
plays with its authentication you as a
user can install this on your edge node
and run without asking your admins to
stand anything else up they don't need
to install extra infrastructure they're
all just Python libraries so they're
they're easy to install they're a pip
installer account install away there's
no need to reach out to other install
mechanisms and they're extensible design
so this is a base class anyone can
implement a new back-end if you have
some fancy hardware we haven't
implemented something for you can write
your own cluster manager and it all just
plug into the ecosystem it's also has
some downsides
so each back-end requires
domain-specific knowledge so as you saw
in the yarn one there we were passing in
environment stuff if you were running on
kubernetes you need to know what a
kubernetes pod looks like this might be
good for expert users but not everyone
has that knowledge that's a little bit
of a ramp up if you're switching between
backends users must have permission and
network access to talk to the resource
manager because we natively integrate
with them you also need to have access
to them so for yarn this looks like you
need to be able to log into the edge
node you need to have permission to run
jobs you need to have
kerberos setup kubernetes you need to
have permission to spin up new pods if
you're on a shared cluster you admin I
want to give that to and then you also
have to have network access because of
how our surety system looks you have
your client which lives in your code and
you have the scheduler which lives
somewhere else
there can't be a firewall between you so
if you have a cluster which has got
ports that are locked off you need to
make sure that you have access to those
ports and you might have to ask admin to
open a portion we don't necessarily want
to open a port for every single user in
your cluster to have their brand-new
scheduler on no central management in
small orgs and actually an in large rx
depends on your team really that might
be fine but many institutions want some
way to audit what's going on with their
system you want to be able to see which
users are using that many resources with
no central management no central desk
server whatever you rely on the back-end
resource manager to do that depending on
your research manager they might have
plenty of facilities for this or they
might not you might just get I have a
pod running and I don't know who started
it and it's hard to enforce good
practices you're you're relying on your
users to be deploying with the proper
configuration using good practices for
managing their resources not leaving a
cluster running for forever and in
clusters are also tied to the lifetime
of the client the current way where
they're deployed as part of code when
you restart your notebook you also end
up restarting a cluster which is both
good and bad often that's what you want
but if you're trying to do a lot of
iterative work you can end up burning
through a lot of resources accidentally
so this brings us to - gateway which is
our attempt to rectify some of these
issues this is just another alternative
I want to stress this is not saying that
the other methods that we've talked
about already are bad this is just a
different one this is trying to solve
those things there are pros and cons so
dowse gateway is a larger architecture
system it's got a server the admins need
to deploy somewhere architecture looks
like this you have a cluster it's got a
firewall around it most clusters do you
have a process that's running the
gateway server
some proxies on it that just runs
somewhere in your cluster users connect
to it through port that's exposed in the
firewall and they're given desc clusters
that as a service excuses the rest api
so users are making rest calls to say
give me a cluster can i can be that
cluster scale it up to end nodes what
clusters do I have everything is
authenticated and secured through a
single port and users don't need to have
direct access to the backing system you
don't need to give them crew Bernese
permissions or yarn permissions this is
all handled by the server as I said
there's a REST API for managing clusters
we have a couple proxies there implement
as part of this we need to build a proxy
desk scheduler traffic through so
between the client and your code and the
scheduler that's running my distributed
system there's some communication we
need to be able to proxy many of those
through so that all users are talking
through the same port we also have proxy
for the dashboards which I'll talk about
in a bit it's a flexible design so just
as before with the old cluster manager
design where we had different backends -
gateway supports different backends it
was really important that we weren't
limited to running just in Korea at ease
you're just done yarn so we support all
of the same ones that we support in
basket of Lee but with this larger
server model and it's also got
configurable authentication so it plays
well with Kerberos plays well with um if
you're deploying Jupiter help we can
plug into their authentication there's a
couple of others and most actions
they're done server-side so the the
gateway server this bit handles most of
these things so you can enforce good
practices you can enforce that users are
turning on adaptive scaling you can
enforce that users clusters scale down
after certain odd time you can set
resource limits using desk gateway so
here's our other example we're creating
a yarn cluster this is the one from
before if we were to do this with desk
gateway we just swap out what kind of
cluster we're creating and that's it the
rest of our code stays the same but now
we're deploying on some admin run server
instead of using the resource manager
natively do a little bit demo I think I
need to make this bigger
yeah the question is at this point the
admin is the user doesn't really care
what it's backed by and that's true yeah
we'll talk about that in a bit
is this big enough for people in the
back yea or nay cool all right
so here I'm connected to this just
happens to be running on kubernetes and
it just happens to have logged me out
anyway it doesn't matter so I'm gonna
deploy a gateway cluster so from the gas
gateway I'm pointing at gateway cluster
and I'm gonna create it
and now I have a cluster object just
like if you're familiar with to ask all
of our cluster managers have this really
nice I PI widgets GUI so if you're
working in a notebook you can do scaling
with the GUI instead of calling scale
manually so here I'm going to scale up
to 3 workers and I should see them up
here and I can connect and then do some
work here we have our dashboard so desk
provides a nice dashboard for auditing
what tasks are going on so each row is a
worker each box is a task so that's a
some task here we're doing a normal
operation and then X is time so you can
see what's going on this is being
proxied through we have a proxy here for
proxying through the dashboard traffic
so the dashboards run on the scheduler
or proxy to me HTTP traffic through to
the users so you only need to have a
single port open for users to get access
to the dashboards if instead I wanted to
adaptively scale maybe I want a scale
between 3 and 0 workers since I have no
tasks going on right now I should see
that drop off pretty quick here yep but
I can run my code again and I should
adaptively scale back up so this is
really nice if you want to make sure
that your users are not keeping
resources when they're not using them
they might be a lot of writing analysis
code is thinking when you're thinking
you don't necessarily need to be using
resources so here we all adaptively
scale back up
to run our tasks again just long enough
to get a response and then we scaled
back down a quick question I have the
question was have I showed the ability
to create a local cluster this is on top
of kubernetes but this is using desk
gateway to manage I'm going fully
understand the question I'm sorry the
difference here is where it's deploying
so here we're using the Gateway cluster
to deploy remotely I'm talking to a
server I will come back to your question
later I'm sorry yeah we'll get two
questions at the end I'm sorry
so besides just having a cluster object
we also provide a gateway client
so that's gateway allows users to keep
long-running clusters up we don't
necessarily shut them down at the end of
a notebook so you can list what clusters
you have here I have one it's the one
I'm connected to provides it a couple
other methods on here I can I can
connect to a running cluster so if I
wanted to connect to the last one here I
can reconnect your cluster that's been
running for a while
shut that down if I wanted to be able to
change options so one thing that people
really wanted the desk gateways provides
is the way to locked out options so in
the previous model you have to give say
we're running a curb in days you have to
give your users permission to launch
kubernetes pods they have to have rocks
this ticker is a API which means they
can do whatever they want
cluster for large organizations that's
not something they might want you might
want to be able to lock down what
features user can do maybe you don't
want them to be able to change what
image they're using or pod security
policies since everything is running
that's talking to the kirino's API is
running on the Gateway server which the
user doesn't have access to and admin
has deployed admins can lock down one
options a user has access to so here we
can see what option them what options
user has access to by calling cluster
options this is going to query the
server to see what the admin has exposed
by default the admin has exposed nothing
here we've set this up to expose worker
course and memory so that a user can
configure their cluster to use four
cores per worker instead of two by
default or a different memory or a
different image but nothing else they
have permission to change no nope
you can also set limits on these so this
is a mapping type object I can try to
change worker course to 20 and it's
gonna give me a nice error that says
we're horse must be less than 4 I got 20
this is checked both client-side for
nice errors and then server side 2 so
the users can't work back around that
there's no quick questions I'm gonna go
back to the presentation yes yes the
questions about pushing custom
environments to the workers so the desk
gateway
finds a lot of plug-in aspects here so
you could handle that yourself exposing
things is it's just a single handler
that's configured well actually I'm just
about to delve into configuration so we
can talk about that so moving back to
the presentation cool
additional features we didn't talk about
resource limits you can set resource
limits you can say a user gets no more
than 100 gigs of memory or you know 20
cores or whatever and they are free to
distribute those throughout workers how
they want but they don't get to use more
resources than they're allowed by the
admin we can automatically shut down an
idle cluster so you can set a timeout
and say if the cluster hasn't been used
to compute anything in 50
minutes kill it you sure can restart it
that helps stop resources for being used
longer than they need and it's got
strong interrupts with super Abbe so if
you're deploying Jupiter hub we can
integrate really nicely with it for off
for plugging into its various
configuration settings and then there's
a couple other things internals so the
rest of this talk we're gonna be talking
about the internals there's a couple
interesting bits that I think are worth
mentioning and it also highlights some
of the architecture so first
configuration so like any server we
needed to be able to pick a
configuration format we needed some way
for admins to say what back-end to use
what ports to Ron so we could use static
files like many projects use ml json
tamil we didn't use any of these so you
have also got some weird edge cases this
is something i found the other day
yamo supports something called
sexagesimal numbers which is a numbering
system used in ancient Sumeria and if it
can lead to MAC addresses being
converted to numbers depending on what
they look like so now it's not the most
consistent format static files also have
issues they're not configurable at
runtime so say you're deploying on a
system and you want to use the hostname
that's on the system you can
programmatically get that but you have
to statically configure it in Yamma or
we'd have to build that into our ml spec
for configuration and we'd also a need a
write our own validation if we're using
these kind of formats so instead we went
with a cool little project called trail
it's trail it's is a Python library it
provides declarative configuration with
automatic valuation configuration is
done as code I'll mention what I mean in
a second and it's the same configuration
system that's used by the whole jupiter
ecosystem so if you've ever tried to add
plugins your configuration type - or
jupiter notebooks it's the same system
so useful trait let's look like if
you're writing code with trail it's you
create a configurable object you define
a couple attributes on it so here we're
defining a configurable width
with the default value of one minimum
value of zero a little help
this shows up in descriptions and
queries and Docs and then we're saying
that yes this is configurable we do the
same for height and then you can use the
attributes down below so here a defining
area is width times height
to configure it in a Python file you can
use tray let's configuration is done
using python syntax there's an automatic
c variable that is a config object
that's injected to this file before it's
run and then you set configure values on
it as attributes so here we're saying
see that rectangle dot width this is
setting the width attribute of a
rectangle default to 10 so going back up
it's a configurable object we had width
and height as configurable variables
tray let's configure looks like this
where you just add C dot whatever the
class name dot whatever they attribute
equals something because this is just
Python though you can do whatever you
want with it so I got a little head of
myself in the code then you load the
config object and it loads the defaults
and you have full access to them because
it has automatic validation I set the
min before as zero if I try to set
something under 0 it's gonna give a nice
error I didn't have to write any the
validation code myself trailers just
does this for you and because it's just
Python code for configuration I can do
complicated things so say we wanted to
support wider rectangles on Windows you
can query just using Python libraries to
do that so this has been really powerful
this has allowed us to integrate well
with other config systems so we have a
helmet chart and we're able to pull our
config on helm from a config map
programmatically in a Python script and
then load it with trail it's rather than
having to build in support directly to
dowse gateway to read a helm config map
we support configurable bakken's as i
mentioned so the example of demo I
showed was running on kubernetes but we
support yarr and we support job queue of
PBS slurm type systems we need a way for
the admins to configure those she need a
way to specify what back-end you
actually want to write on so the way we
did that was we abstracted all the
backends
civic things out into a base class which
we're also calling a cluster manager
which is a little confusing and then we
implement that class for various
backends so we have a crewman Aires
cluster manager we have a yarn cluster
manager implementation and then the
backing class is configurable using the
trait let's type treatment so just as I
assigned width equals float before we're
using a type one here to have a
configurable class base class it's got a
couple standard methods on it
start cluster cluster status cluster
same for workers these can be defined
for probably any back-end system if you
can run a process you can probably
define these two different things so
this is also extensible you don't have
to have built-in support so just as
before with our previous it status quo
method if you have some custom hardware
if there's a back-end we don't currently
support you as a user as an admin can
write your own base class here your own
cluster manager bloatation and plug in a
desk gateway and everything should just
work cool and then this shows the
configuration so here were defining to
use the cube cluster manager same as
trailers before just Python code we
assign the class and then we need to
configure attributes on the cube cluster
manager instead of the desk gateway any
quick questions about Trail it's yes
yeah I'm just covering this whole part
of the talk is just things I think that
are useful outside of deskaway this is
things I learned while writing it so
trayless is a nice library I recommend
people use it it's good I'm sorry I said
it again
yeah so the question is can you put
arbitrary path and go in there and there
yeah the answer is yes this is a Python
script all that's done is that a C
variable which is a config map is
injected into the namespace before this
is run so you have a variable that
already exists called C everything else
is you can do whatever you want the same
it was like it's dangerous it could be
dangerous this the rulers that admins
should be doing this and users shouldn't
have a way to write over this but it
also is powerful it allows a lot of nice
behaviors that no any other quick
questions on this before we move on all
right another thing so there's a
scheduler proxy component of this so
tasks uses raw TCP to communicate most
proxies are either level seven proxies
they they proxy HTTP so they can
dispatch on the path of the HTTP request
or they proxy TCP to a static address we
wanted to be able to dispatch but we
also wanted to be able to use TCP in the
proxy we also actually wanted to encrypt
this too we want to make sure that our
traffic is encrypted so that we're
secure no one can be sniffing what kind
of data you're passing around we could
include custom protocol so in our in our
messages that we're passing between the
task client and the House scheduler we
could include something to dispatch on
but that would require our scheduler
proxy to decrypt the message to figure
out where routing to so the solution was
to use something called the server name
indication this is part of the TLS spec
it's a little header that's part of the
handshake that's unencrypted that can be
used to pass in something like a server
name which is what many proxies use this
as or in our case it's a clustered name
that we're going to route to and it
allows routing TLS encrypted traffic
without decrypting it but just looking
at the unencrypted server name in the
handshake
so the basic loop in the scheduler proxy
is on each Connection we get we pull out
the s and I
sherburn a munication from the handshake
we check a routing table we see if we
have one then we just replay the entire
connection on another socket and the
rest of the proxy is just copying bytes
from one socket or another which is very
very fast we don't have to do any TLS
decryption we don't have to do anything
complicated with just routing this is
all written and go extended to do some
low-level bytes handling it's good
support for handling many clients it's
good good async i/o and the standard Lib
had a bunch of features that I wanted
that made this easy to do I also wanted
to write go and done it before and it's
bundled in with the Python project so if
you haven't done this before
setup tools has a feature called
packaged data which allows you to bundle
arbitrary files in with your wheel so we
just bundle in our little go application
as packaged it and we can run it as part
of our code this makes it really easy
for users to install you can still pip
install deskaway server and you get the
go code bundle along with it testing so
as you can imagine we have kubernetes
yarns lerm PBS local processes probably
adding more we have a lot of different
backends we need to test against we also
have different authentication to test
against many different server features
client features our test matrix rather
huge we want to test to be thorough but
also fast and we want to be actually we
could actually test on all these
backends so the solution for the cluster
backends was we have a generic test
class PI test lets you write a test
class and then you can parameterize that
on various other implementations so we
have a generic test class for testing a
cluster manager back-end that tests say
start cluster works properly start
worker works properly we walk through a
bunch of standard workloads we
parameterize these on each back-end and
then we run them in a docker I setup so
we have docker containers that stand up
each of our different kubernetes CR and
PB s theorem we have one for running
each of those if you're interested in
how those work I have a link here these
slides are gonna be on line two later
and then the tester on they run if
they're needed
Travis CI has a feature for doing
conditional builds where you can cancel
branches that you don't need in a PR so
this allows us to run our tests pretty
fast usually the yarn code doesn't
change every PR but when it does we
could actually test the cluster back
into works and in the main application
most of our server tests for server
behavior run in one process so we have
an in process cluster manager
implementation that runs everything in
async i/o tasks this makes it really
easy to inject failures so we can kill
workers arbitrarily kill schedulers
arbitrarily let's just make sure that
our code is running robustly but also
keeps air tests pretty quick to run and
it also is really nice you can use PDB
if you're running everything in the same
process to inspect a global state so
what would normally be a distributed
cluster we have schedulers and workers
and clients and the desk gateway server
running as separate processes we can run
in the same process using async i/o and
check the global states as consistent we
use PI test async io 4 async IO tests
it's a great library if you haven't
written a lot of async code I recommend
using this if you ever have to for
testing cool conclusion so DDoS gateway
which is what this talk is about is
essentially managed gateway server so
this provides central managing of -
clusters admins set things up once users
can connect they don't have to do
anything complicated they don't have to
know anything specific about the backend
they can just request a new cluster
secure by default automatic TLS goes
everywhere no elevated user permissions
you just don't need direct access to the
backend cluster they just need to be
able to talk to the Gateway server it's
flexible we support many different
cluster backends many different
authentication methods through Buster
failure which I actually didn't get to
but you can kill the Gateway server and
restart it and everything continues to
work so we can do nice smooth upgrades
failover it's designed with
institutional members or teams in mind
the previous methods I talked about the
beginning of this talk are still very
valid very useful I'm still recommended
for many use cases so this is not a
replacement this is another solution for
cases that need it extra research
so all of our Doc's are available at
Gateway org we have nice installs guides
for installing locally on a Hadoop
cluster cluster HPC job queue we have
user guides yeah hopefully our hopefully
our Doc's are thorough and then if you
actually want to contribute or ask
issues it's available at desk slash desk
gateway on github and then we have our
main desk website questions so I have
one classification of one question I
assume that a user can use multiple
clusters like if they have multiple
notebooks with long-running jobs can
make kind of different ones yes
so yes users can multiple clusters one
of our user limit settings is a max
clusters so an admin can say users can
have no more than four running
concurrently yes
what do you see yeah so the question is
what they're actually you have a mic so
I don't have to repeat it that's great
the the biggest thing that needs to
happen is so desk gateway is a lot like
Jupiter hub we cribbed a lot of their
design it's a great project if you don't
like to know Jupiter hub runs many
jupiter notebooks in the same way that -
gateway runs many desks servers but we
also inherited some of their weaknesses
so my the main plan for the near future
is to move to a multi server model so
right now you can only have one gateway
server running as opposed to other web
apps where you might run many of them
behind a load balancer the Gateway
server keeps a lot of internal state it
keeps it out of database but it's not
designed for concurrent server access
that's partly because we inherited from
Jupiter hub that limitation that's
probably because I've never written a
web application before and didn't really
what I was doing so yeah that's the near
future design is to move things to make
better use of the database for
concurrency so we can run multiple
servers so question from before because
what you're showing here is that you're
working through a gateway that talks to
several other resource management
systems youngs over dusk on its own just
playful not just a scheduler and you
spawn workers replaces this the only
thing it doesn't do is give you
different users and yeah you I'm not
sure how much you can allocate resources
or not but in today's world the old ways
of actually creating clusters for users
going away because people just went on
the cloud a bunch of computers and use
them so specifically to do this are you
gonna go and develop tasks more so those
systems look gonna go away eventually or
are you always gonna support them some
degree and piggyback Fightin's
whatever you're giving or are they
giving some functions that are very
important that you don't want us to do
real quick clarification for answer what
sorry are the what system is gonna go
away when you said systems I mean the
old the resource management system like
slurm is a resource management system
basically it gives you resources
it creates a cluster for you so you
don't need the creation of the cluster
because task itself can create the
cluster
why are you like I know that you want to
serve them for now but in the future
don't want to inherit some of those
things that they are doing and go in
other directions it's a long
philosophical questions but like where
are you going to this because dusk is
already powerful
zone why are we supporting those all
systems because people used the old
systems so many many like universities
have a slurm cluster we want to make
sure that things run well on them doing
the smart things that's for sure
so yes there are some cases where you
need to share resources but the world is
going to a place where we actually can
isolate you can create on virtualized
machines that are only your own you no
longer need to manage the users as
before so you saying that you just just
because there's a current need you want
to support it I think that there are
many different use case for things and I
think that saying that across the board
that a slurm cluster is a bad thing is
not necessarily submit with support so
here is my give me a use case where
actually this is needed and you don't
want a task to actually go in some other
system I think we can talk more after
this yeah so I'm gonna tribute you're in
question is how does spark compare to
desk rather than okay so dead-ass
gateways just for deploying it runs the
same everywhere we have a whole page in
our Doc's about the comparison between
desk and spark I recommend that you you
look for that I can I can send you the
link if you ask in general tasks and
spark solve the same problem one will be
for more performant on some things we
won't perform another one thing that we
think that we do well in comparison is
that task is more flexible the backing
paradigm is distributed acyclic graphs
spark has a little bit more of a
higher-level structure on top of it so
you can do a little bit more route how
scheduling that might not mean things to
mow
suitors but if you if you really need to
reach out and do complicated things task
is more flexible we also written in pure
Python so you're gonna get trace backs
that are in Python you're gonna get it
feels a little bit more like pandas than
like so so logging logging so from
question I know there's there's an open
issue every back-end handles logging
differently we would like to be able to
track that out in some way so we can
have a generic log provider yarn does it
for you like all your jobs get logging
for free communities has a billion
different solutions it seems so log is
an open open question
NASA does log we just don't know what to
do with the Cabrini's logs and we're
yeah so so authentication protocols we
support Kerberos we support plugging
into Jupiter hub which can use the trick
here's this is a this is a REST API
meant for not humans talking over a
browser so so we need to make sure that
we support protocols that don't require
human-like in the loop so that's really
that Kerberos can do that with a ticket
we can do that by using the token that
you better have generates but but other
things would require like a web type
form much a little harder to play with
so authentication is another open
question what things will should we
support and what things should be pumped
on if there's something that you need
that'd be nice to talk to anyone else
if someone was just getting started with
setting up distributed work flow do you
think gas gateway is the most sort of
convenient way to attack that problem No
so it depends if you're just trying to
get started desk I recommend using desk
locally I remember I recommend just
creating a local cluster you can do that
by calling client with no parameters and
you're good to go everything just works
if you are trying to get things running
remotely and it's just you I also
recommend not using desk a way that's
great way is mainly meant for teams it's
meant for admins that want security and
auditing it's it's meant for easing the
burden on non-expert users the person
setting up to ask gateway still needs to
be an expert user but then other future
users might not need to be so well well
thank you
[Applause]